foreign
[Music]
for the first time in my life and it's
kind of surreal
I'm up here on a rooftop and I'm seeing
two giant flagpoles
I mean that is a massive flagpole
you go over this wall and you're not
actually in North Korea yet you're in a
No Man's Land a Four Mile thick
demilitarized zone that effectively
comprises the Border
I came to this border
because I want to understand this in a
new way I'm tired of watching this
intensifying showdown with North Korea
the North Koreans are in no mood to talk
they're in the mood of testing and
blowing things up
getting one very specific version fed to
me about what this conflict is about
Rogue regime in Pyongyang nuclear
testing is a big deal another nuclear
test at any time who it's between why it
exists the missile that North Koreans
launch is something the U.S has never
seen before Kim's stockpile of nuclear
weapons capable of hitting the
continental United States instead I want
to see it for myself to talk to the
people who live in South Korea's capital
a city of 10 million people that is 40
kilometers from this border I hear
there's a lot of bomb shelters in Seoul
I want to go see what those look like
foreign
border what it looks like what it feels
like and most importantly how it got
here
[Music]
not fed through Western diplomacy
military policy and media coverage but
rather what it actually looks like on
the ground
[Music]
against the Communists
[Music]
I'm drowning in some of the coolest
evidence I've ever touched in my life
which are original telegrams between
Stalin and Kim il-sung I've got a ton of
this stuff and frankly it's very very
useful for understanding this border
this line that divided the Korean
Peninsula what I first need to do is
thank today's sponsor who made this
ambitious video possible copilot is a
platform where you get paired with a
fitness coach one-on-one it's like a
personalized coach and you get to craft
a fitness plan that works for you I went
through the the whole process of getting
paired up with the code hey Donnie it's
a pleasure is there any injuries aches
or pains that I need to be cognizant
then I got to have my first workout it
shows me what I'm supposed to do the
best part about this is that it's
tailored to my life what I can actually
do how much time I actually want to
spend doing this
that's time copilot makes it so much
easier to fit exercise into your life
what are you using I forgot my dumbbells
so I'm using the sandbags here in the
studio so much of what we hear about
Fitness is focused on transforming how
you look what I love about copilot it's
about consistent movement to improve how
you feel how your mind works and what
you can do with your body I'm so in line
with those values after a workout I
could let them know if something was off
or if I wanted to change the focus
workout was good today I do wish that
there was more and I could get a
response with additional feedback being
implemented into future workouts you get
unlimited back and forth in app texting
with your coach and unlimited video
calls like it's it's really amazing so
if this sounds interesting to you you
can get 14 days for free with your own
Expert Fitness and health coach at the
link in my description it's
go.myco-pilot.com Johnny Harris clicking
that link helps support this channel as
always but it also gets you in on this
deal of two weeks for free to start your
journey with copilot I've loved loved it
and I think you will too so with that
let's get back to North Korea
this line this peninsula we've all heard
something about it I studied this line a
lot in college and in grad school at the
think tank I worked at but for this
story I wanted to throw out all of that
training all of that perspective I
wanted to approach it with a new lens
one not steeped in the assumptions and
biases of American foreign policy media
and Military thinking so let me show you
my new perspective on how this line came
to be
Korea was an independent unified place
until the early 1900s when Japan annexed
it as part of their conquest of Asia
then the world responded beating them
back and crushing this growing Empire
that's World War II the winners of the
war got together and decided that yes we
just liberated Korea from Japan but no
they are not ready to be independent
just yet the two most powerful allies
decided that they would each occupy half
of the peninsula for up to five years
then Koreans could have one independent
country this whole Peninsula most
Koreans of course hated this more
colonizers using their Peninsula as a
military base but the gray Powers didn't
really care so late one night in 1945
right before Japan surrendered two U.S
military leaders got together here in
the Pentagon and pulled out this map
this map actually
this is a 1942 National Geographic map
that these two military leaders used to
split Korea they eyeballed this
peninsula and they proposed this line
here at 38 North it's like a latitude
line and surprisingly to them the
Soviets agreed 38th parallel
with this line the Americans were trying
to get Seoul which was Korea's capital
on their side of the line which they did
by just like 40 kilometers
oh and just to be clear here this line
the 38th parallel wasn't some natural
border it wasn't a linguistic or
cultural border but again the whole idea
was that this was just going to be
temporary it's going to last five years
two great Powers dividing land with maps
temporarily what could go wrong
[Music]
okay so what's the deal with the Soviet
Union and the United States in this
moment you have to remember that they
were allies after World War II because
they had fought a common enemy banding
together to crush the Nazi Empire in
Europe and then the Soviets joined in
over here in Asia kind of last second to
help deal the final blows to the
Japanese empire so these two superpowers
were friends I mean I have direct proof
of this check out a picture of my
grandpa in the late 40s on the Korean
Peninsula he's standing right up here on
the border between the Soviet Union and
Korea and he's hanging out with the
Soviet soldier with a big smile on his
face the Soviets and Americans were
allies they were friends they had worked
together here but very quickly they
started to realize how much they
actually weren't friends and that they
thought very differently about how the
world should work and in fact now that
other big Empires were out of the way
the entire world was now a chessboard
open for them to make their moves to
ensure that their ideology would become
the new way of the world yes we want to
to give Korea back to the Koreans said
the Soviet Union and the United States
but will it be an American friendly
capitalist Society or a soviet-friendly
communist Society meanwhile the local
Koreans at least most of them were
hating all of this but there was one
Korean who was not hating it the new
leader of the soviet-backed north
kinnelsung who was a war guy he rose up
as a fighter in China's Communist
Revolution and was picked to then lead
the Communist part of Korea Kim wanted
to unite the peninsula under communism
with Force
but he couldn't do that without the
blessing of his Soviet supporters mainly
this guy Joseph Stalin and this is where
the evidence we found gets pretty juicy
among Communists Kim is the last to
maintain a personality cult okay check
these out these are telegrams and
conversations between Joseph Stalin and
Kim il-sung I mean this is like the when
you are looking at original
conversations in the original text from
these great leaders which have since
been Declassified by the presidential
archives in Moscow you learn more from
this than you do from any textbook or
any master's degree because this is like
the horse's mouth this is what they were
actually saying you start to get the
first insights into how the Cold War
would start to play out the logic the
calculations the fears the goals okay so
it's a 1949 Kim il-sung immediately goes
to Stalin asking for support and weapons
to invade the South to unite the
peninsula under the Communist flag not
surprisingly Stalin is very very
interested in communism winning out on
the Korean peninsula but you read these
conversations and you see that he's also
kind of freaked out the Americans are
there and a direct conflict with these
two superpowers is a recipe for another
global war Plus
China which is another communist Ally is
currently in a big Civil War they're not
going to be able to help Kim out in his
efforts so Stalin basically says no
but then the next year 1950 three big
things change
[Music]
Stalin sends a note to Kim saying he's
quote ready to help him in this matter
tell him to come to Moscow
thing number one Stalin got Intel from
one of his spies in Washington that
South Korea wasn't that important to the
Americans and if there was an invasion
the Americans probably wouldn't do
anything U.S troops were leaving the
peninsula thing number two and this is a
big freaking deal Stalin says it right
here that quote the USSR now has the
atomic bomb ending the US's Atomic
Monopoly that changes everything and
thing number three and again we see this
in another conversation Stalin says to
Kim in one of these meetings the
Communists in China had just won their
Civil War they control China now they're
not busy with the Civil War and they'll
be able to help with an invasion of
South Korea with these three major
developments Stalin now feels secure
that the U.S won't come to quote
challenge the Communists in Asia it
would be an easy Victory oh and at the
end of all these conversations Stalin is
like side note we will support you we
will give you weapons but we're not
going to send troops go ask Mao for
those which is exactly what he did it so
do you see what's happening here this is
like cold war like crash course it is
spies prevailing mood is not to
interfere in the U.S it is global
ideological alliances Chinese Victory is
also important psychologically and it is
nuclear deterrence the USSR now has the
atomic bomb the seeds of the Cold War
are sprouting after three years of
preparation the Soviet Union and its
North Korean prophets were ready troops
and military equipment poured down from
the north so then early one morning in
June of 1950 it happened some 75 000
soldiers from the north blast across
this line a line that two American
Military guys had drawn five years
earlier June 25th 1950 the Communist
strike and as Kim il-sung predicted his
troops quickly took over nearly the
entire Peninsula but Stalin's
calculation was wrong back in Washington
President Truman wasn't going to let the
Communists take over the Korean
Peninsula the future of civilization
depends on what we do on what we do now
he got ready for war bypassing Congress
to prepare to get a bunch of U.N Nations
together to come to Korea's rescue
obstacles United Nations Forces drive on
parallel border of North Korea the
details of what happened next are
astounding and frankly I have no idea
why I didn't learn these details in
school this was a brutal and long War
incredibly destructive the entire
Peninsula was ripped apart but an
important detail for this story is what
the U.S Air Force did up here in the
north the versatility of Air Forces was
proved as never before with their new
jet-powered aircraft they quickly
established air superiority and dropped
an unfathomable amount of explosives
onto North Korea like it's hard to
quantify but to put into perspective the
US Air Force dropped more bombs on North
Korea in this three-year period than
they did during the entire Pacific
Theater of World War II after
identifying their targets our planes
swooped down like avenging Shadows of
death and destruction
thank you
the U.S Air Force targeted basically
anything that moved Villages towns
buildings factories and very importantly
dams U.S carrier-based planes take off
their target the vital hydroelectric
power plants south of the yalo river
unleashing a flood of water that washed
away Villages and killed the water
supply to rice and other crops leading
to an excruciatingly slow starvation of
the people who started Living in a
network of underground caves to escape
the bombardment of their country an
advance whose purpose General Ridgeway
States is not to seize ground but to
wipe out the enemy in the end 85 of all
buildings in North Korea were destroyed
85 the Communists had finally launched
their undeclared all-out war of Conquest
now wait I know what you're thinking if
you're familiar with this conflict which
is that this entire Peninsula got
slammed it wasn't just the north the
North and the South Seoul was turned to
dust as well this was a horrifying War
the reason I'm highlighting the utter
destruction and the aerial bombardment
of the north is because what the U.S Air
Force did here this this memory became a
foundational memory for these people it
would go on to inform the rest of the
country's history to this day this
memory would not fade
this horrific War went on for three
years until 1953 when they signed a
ceasefire freezing the front line of the
war where it was on the day they signed
right here the agreement was to take
this line and put a two kilometer buffer
on each side declaring it a Zone where
no military activity can occur a
demilitarized zone
[Music]
so where I'm standing now is the
demilitarized zone the DMZ
no military stuff allowed within this
four kilometer thick buffer zone up here
in North Korea down here South Korea and
these borders are some of the most
fortified and militarized lines on our
planet
after the war the American Military
never went home and since then there
have been tens of thousands of troops on
this peninsula oh and crucially the U.S
stored nuclear weapons on this peninsula
during the Cold War providing South
Korea with the security they needed to
turn into a thriving Advanced democracy
helping them build their country to move
on from the trauma and pain of this war
and like I said earlier North Korea did
the opposite they didn't move on they
stayed fixated on what happened during
those three years of horror continuing
to build up anti-aircraft defenses
underground bunkers and tunnels and over
the course of decades their Soviet
supporters helped them learn the science
of nuclear energy that by 2006 turned
into nuclear weapons North Korea
becoming the eighth country to possess
the most destructive weapons in the
world and as the Soviet Union collapsed
and cut off all of its support North
Korea used this one weapon to stay in
the conversation to ensure that they
would never find themselves in this
situation again
as one historian from Columbia
University said
North Korea never forgot the lessons of
their vulnerability from American
airstrikes and that the long-term
psychological effects of the war on the
whole of North Korean Society cannot be
overestimated the war against the United
States more than any other single Factor
gave North Koreans a collective sense of
anxiety and fear of outside threats that
would continue long after the war's End
North Korea keeps this memory alive
through horrific imagery there's
actually a museum just south of
Pyongyang that's dedicated to the
atrocities committed by the United
States you walk into this place and it
is full of horrific imagery like
paintings of Americans doing terrible
things to North Koreans I'm not going to
show you any of this propaganda here
because it is gruesome and horrifying oh
and the target audience of this Museum
children every year young children make
up pilgrimage to this Museum to witness
these images and affirm in their minds
their hatred for the United States and
their desire for Revenge keeping alive
this memory from the 1950s
the regime keeps this memory alive to
keep their people scared and oppressed
constantly Ready for War
back in Seoul
every few years North Korea comes out
and says that they are ready and willing
to turn this city into a sea of fire or
a pile of ashes and frankly they have
the tools to do it up here on this
border there are over 10 000 big
military guns pointed at this city these
guns have a range of over 60 kilometers
which puts Seoul very much in range
luckily people in this city are ready
there are over 3 000 bomb shelters
sprinkled throughout Seoul and that is
what I'm looking for today
[Music]
luckily the government made an app to
show the people of Seoul where all of
these bomb shelters are
[Music]
wait this is the bomb shelter
I mean I guess we're underground but
like
barely gotta talk to one of these shop
owners see what they think
[Music]
did you know that this was a bomb
shelter I guess is the question
is
that one was just a shopping mall
come on let's go somewhere else on the
map
[Music]
wait so the next bomb shelter on this
map
is a Starbucks
what so did you know that there's a bomb
shelter I didn't know that I've never
noticed that
um so this is it this is the bomb
shelter
the basement of this apartment complex
um
let's go visit another one I guess
foreign
Ed another shelter
[Music]
now I'm really in a bomb shelter
oh actually it's just another parking
garage what is this I mean it's just
like if we had to rush down here is
there water
is there extra food is there some way to
seal it off so that chemical weapons
don't get down here no it's literally an
unchanged parking garage not retrofitted
not special in any way I'm starting to
lose faith in the idea that these bomb
shelters are anything but just normal
City infrastructure that have signs on
them that say these are bomb shelters do
these people not realize they live 40
kilometers from North Korea
what I'm making a video about sort of
the American perspective okay of North
Korea which is like have you ever
thought through like a scenario of like
what you would do in case of an attack
oh
you don't
um
I've actually never thought about it
we just hate the regime and oh my God
and you know as I told you I've lived
here for my whole life and I've seen
them like testing nuclear weapons and
you know but like we don't really care
and no listen let me just be frank I'm
slightly playing up my ignorance here I
kind of knew that this was the case but
I also kind of didn't as an American who
studied this conflict through an
American foreign policy lens my hunt for
bomb shelters and the subsequent
conversations with locals drove home
just how little the people here actually
think about North Korea I don't think
I've ever met anyone in Korea who was
like really worried about that
[Music]
Kim Jong-un doesn't do this to threaten
South Korea they do this to threaten us
the United States the military that
turned their country into dust in the
1950s the country that they are
technically still at war with
[Music]
back up here at the border you can see
what the conflict actually looks like
today between North and South there's
occasional violence but the conflict
today is often more Petty
who can build the largest flagpole who
can blast the loudest music at each
other North Korea comically building a
fake City to look more prosperous and a
competition of who can look the scariest
you realize that it's not actually scary
or threatening to be here if anything
it's just plain sad it's sad to see 70
years of this standoff this needless
standoff that was created by powerful
Outsiders and once again what we see is
that the people who share the same
history and culture and language but are
divided continue to be the ones that
suffer from this
[Music]
through my time in the DMZ I decided to
set aside the history the Bluster the
fear just for a moment to experience
this place not as an American taught to
see this region purely in terms of
conflict but to experience it as the
people here experience it the people
here in this city that is unrecognizable
from the devastation of the 50s
city that has moved on
[Music]
it is a Saturday night here in Seoul
South Korea the Sun is going down I
spent the night traversing this city
immersing myself in what it has to offer
from the nightclubs to barbecue to small
underground clubs watching DJ
competitions and sipping Soju then to a
street party in the middle of the night
where a bunch of young people are
protesting the forced eviction and
planned demolition of this historic Pub
one of seoul's oldest institutions for
beer and dried fish
they've been doing this every night for
months yes North Korea is 40 kilometers
away I'm very aware of that there's a
real threat here a dangerous oppressive
regime with powerful weapons but the
threat presents very differently for the
people here much differently than the
fear that we feel an ocean away I walked
away from Korea with a much clearer
understanding of this conflict this
conflict that was started by North Korea
fueled by Cold War Dynamics and remains
an active war between North Korea and
the United States of America
foreign
thank you for watching this video I'm
really looking forward to your thoughts
and once again I want to thank the
sponsor of today's video I'm two weeks
into my journey with copilot this
platform that allows me to have
one-on-one interaction with a fitness
coach and I can tell you it is making a
giant difference in just accountability
and I'm not alone in this co-pilot
clients are nine times more successful
at sticking with their goals and that's
not surprising to me so go click the
link in my description to get 14 days
free with your own Expert Fitness and
health coach thank you co-pilot for
sorting this video thank you all for
watching I will see you in the next one
foreign
[Music]